welcome back to my round seven recap
from kregero
I didn't have time to record the recap
after this game finished because it was
such a long game and the funny thing
about this game I thought I was gonna be
winning within the first like 15 or 20
moves
uh so I was playing a player by the name
of Isaac Vin Bros apologies if I'm
butchering the pronunciation I think
he's from Norway and it's a pretty young
player
um maybe 13 or 14 years old I've been
playing a lot of uh a lot of players
younger than me this tournament so this
opponent is no different and I wasn't
able to find too many of my opponents
games online beforehand but I saw a few
games where he was playing Dutch against
D4 and C4
and in this game I decided to play a
move on move one that I almost never
play that being Knight to F3 and the
reason why I played this move is because
I was expecting the Dutch is what he
played and I had a very tricky line
prepared Pawn to D3
um so this avoids like the main lines
where white already has uh D4 C4 played
and the idea of D3 is actually to go for
a very quick E4 and there's some really
interesting Gambit lines that can occur
from this now we didn't go into a Gambit
specifically but just to show if black
plays one of the most natural moves
Knight F6 I would play E4 and basically
sack the pawn in the center and then
play Bishop D3 and I Was preparing this
before the game and there's a lot of
cool variations that can arise here for
example if Knight F6 then Knight to G5
is playable and there's already threats
of taking on each seven followed by
Bishop G6 checkmates so I was excited to
go into some of these lines but instead
of playing Knight F6 he very quickly
played D6
and he was actually playing the opening
very quickly which surprised me a little
bit because this is a pretty rare
variation and there is no way he
prepared this before the game because I
don't think I've ever played this like
even online so I play E4 this is still
prep Pawn to E5 and Knight to C3
now one more tidbit about this opening
that I'm just remembering uh I first
discovered this line
pack in I want to say 2013 or 2014 and I
was actually preparing this against none
other than Levy Rosman at the Chicago
open I think that was the last time I
played 903 on move one in a tournament
game
um or at least one of the last times uh
now Levy in that game played G6 and uh
we went on different routes but um I
finally managed to get this line in a
tournament after about 10 years
so um we got to this position Knight C3
and Knight to F6 was played and this
resembles some sort of like reverse
Kings Gambit declined maybe some kind of
philodor type setup for Black now I knew
he plays Cairo Khan against E4 so I was
trying to just get a structure that he'd
be less familiar with and I was still in
prep here I took the pawn takes and then
I play Pawn to D4
and it looks a little bit weird because
I've played D3 and D4 uh within the
first few moves of the game but D4 is
very much Justified here because I have
the two knights developed and I'm
hitting the pawn on E5 and there's a
line here that
um you didn't go into but if he plays E4
then white can get away with Knight H4
and it's a bit awkward for black to find
a square for the bishop because if
Bishop E6 I have D5 Bishop F7 and Knight
F5 and this was my pre-game prep uh
there's a cool idea of G6 there's Knight
H6 and I'd get the bishop pair but we
went a different route uh he played
Knight to C6 and I also looked at this
position before the game I played Bishop
to B5 he took I took and uh yeah before
the game maybe about like 20 minutes
before I had this position on my
computer and I was prepared for Bishop
to D7
and then what was I planning to play
oh yeah I was gonna Castle
I just want to show like my uh the
extent of my preparation
um it's looking at takes takes takes
takes and then if Bishop E7 there's this
cool idea Queen C4 getting initiative
against the C7 Pawn also preventing
black from castling and then if this
then there's this move and there's 96
ideas and I believe the engine will will
give a small Plus for white here
so it's been a common theme in this
tournament that I I try and prepare as
deeply as possible in a lot of obscure
lines for my opponents and sometimes it
works out in this game I'd say it did
work out because instead of playing
Bishop D7 which should be played uh my
opponent played a very questionable move
Queen's E7 check
and the issue with this move is it just
hampers the development of the darks for
Bishop and it aligns a king and the
Queen on the open file So eventually I
really want to get a rook to E1 and it
doesn't really address the threat of uh
the bishop hanging and the Knight being
attacked as well
uh so after Queen E7 I was pretty
pleased to see this move and I actually
took a moment here and I ended up
playing the most natural move Bishop to
E3 but for brief moments
I really was curious about this move
King to D2 essentially bong clouding but
threatening Rook to Iman and there's the
additional threats of this and this and
I couldn't get myself to even take this
move seriously just during the game I
assumed that King D2 is ridiculous but I
do want to check with engine if this is
playable because I was dreaming of like
playing King D2 and then making like a
over-the-top YouTube thumbnail with a
title Bond cloud in all caps but uh
let's see King D2 is this playable for
whites
wow
wow why it's not worse here black has to
equalize with 94.
that's cool that like White's position
is so good that Bond clouding is
possible and uh it's not not losing but
uh yeah let's go back to what happened
in the game I play Bishop E3 and yeah
like the same person I just want to
Castle and get the Rook to E1 he plays
Bishop to D7 I castle and then he plays
Knight T5 and I wasn't actually
anticipating this move but it's very
logical because for one he's blocking or
trying to block the file also trying to
initiate some trade and maybe repairing
Pawn C6
and then in this position I I calculated
a funny line that we ended up getting in
the game
um I started with bishop 2g5 and after
C6 there's a really nice idea for white
not to move the bishop but to play Pawn
F4
and once I played this move I was
feeling very very good about the
position there's a lot of issues for
black given the knights hanging the king
and queen are aligned rookie one is
bound to happen and if that Bishop is
taken then all of a sudden there's
Knight D5 possibilities hitting so many
Targets in Black's position at this
point I thought the game might just be
over within a few more moves but boy was
I wrong uh and from here my opponent
actually was very resourceful and
managed to keep fighting starting with
castle and queen side
and it's a clever move because after
takes takes I'm temporarily up a minor
piece but my knight and Bishop are
hanging I saw this coming and I I had a
move-in store Knight to B3 with idea
that after he takes I play Knight to D5
and this is a position that we got and
it looks like White's winning here
pretty cleanly because I'm hitting the
Queen the knights and I'm ready to take
take and then just win eventually win
The Exchange and be up a decisive amount
of material
but then he plays Queen E6 and after
takes takes takes he plays Bishop E7
here and I began to realize that the
position is actually not that simple
after I win material
my pieces aren't too impressive
especially the nylon B3 and Rook on A1
and his Bishops can very quickly come to
life
if the bishop comes to C6 and Rook comes
to G8 there can be a lot of pressure
against my king side and of course this
bishop is dreaming to come to this G1 A7
diagonal as fortunate the Knight stops
Bishop C5 here but uh yeah once we got
this position I realized the game's not
going to be ending anytime soon and it
still requires a lot of work so I start
with Queen H5 which I thought is a nice
move preparing Rook E1 and I really want
to pressure this I sort of e-pawn
he plays Rook G8 and I play Rook to F2 I
wanted to play rookie one but I wasn't
sure about
I wasn't sure about Rook G5
and then if I take the pawn there's all
of a sudden like Rook takes G2
uh this line scared me a little bit
because King takes G2 Queen G4 if I go
in the corner then Bishop C6 happens it
just looked really scary
and I figured Rook F2 is just a safe
move make sure there's no funny business
on on G2 so he plays A5 here and yeah A5
I think it was played with good
intention he's trying to remove my
Knights so the bishop can come in but I
think this was a little bit too slow
because I have rookie one and not only
am I attacking the pawn but I'm also
pinning the pawn so I'm setting up ideas
of Knight D4 and uh yeah black isn't in
time to play Pawnee for uh he starts
with Rook G5 I win H7 and then he plays
Bishop to C6
and
yeah around here I thought like
initially I thought I was going to be
winning very easily with this move
Knight D4
which looks like it just um Forks the
queen and Bishop now I didn't end up
playing this move but let me show this
on the board uh because this is a nice
looking move combining the pin and the
fork so basically the pork uh but black
has a really really cool response which
is basically the reason why I didn't
play Knight D4 black has a move Bishop
C5 here essentially meeting the pork
with the shish kebab on this diagonal
and if I take the queen
then Rook takes G2 and this is also a
pork because the Rook is pinned and King
and Rook are Fort and I think
is white losing here I mean it's at
least Perpetual check but I did not want
to go into this position so for that
reason I didn't play Knight T4 I took a
long think and I started with Queen H.A
check with idea that if the king moves
to C7 then I can play Knight D4 and if
Bishop C5 now I take the queen with Jack
and it's a triple Fork so a lot of the
Tactical possibilities here but he
didn't play King to C7 he played King D7
so I still don't have Knight D4 because
of the same reason I think I haven't
checked this with engine so maybe I
missed something but I still didn't want
to play Knight D4 and I decided on the
Move
um Pawn to H4
and when I played Pawn H4 I realized
he had a really cool response which um I
I did see before I played H4 but it does
look scary he responded with the move
Queen H3 which is just a really cool
resource uh pinning the pawn from behind
threatening G2 now three times and
um yeah I can't take the rook and it
looks scary for white but uh there was a
move to stay live here there's Rook D1
check and after he played King C7 I was
able to simplify with Queen takes E5
Rook takes E5 and pawn takes H3 so very
fancy way of trading down and when I saw
this position from a distance I thought
it should be a pretty routine win
because I'm up the exchange and a pawn
after Bishop takes H4 however it's it's
very far from simple because the Bishops
are just so strong especially in a widow
position my Knights is still a little
bit awkward on B3 and black has
initiative
so we keep going I play Rook to F4 he
attacks The Rook I check he plays King
B6 and I play Knight D4 so finally
getting the Knight to a better Central
Square and it's my dream to trade the
Knight for one of the black's Bishops
but he avoids the trade attacks a rook
and rather than moving The Rook I go for
a counter attack Knight F3 and now it
looks really messy because so many
things are attacked in various
directions but uh I'm not really forcing
the trades here because he has Bishop E3
after I move my king he just moves his
rook and now everything's defended in
Black's position and my Rook is still
attacked so I gave a check he moved back
and then I played Pawn to B3 which is
kind of solidifying the the queen side
ensuring there's no Bishop C4 check or
Bishop takes A2 and the game keeps going
from here he plays Bishop C6 I play
rookie one when I played rookie one I
had a sneaky idea I was hoping he would
um he would try and set up a trap but
then there was actually a counter trap
now he didn't walk into the the line I
was hoping for but I was hoping for
Bishop C5
with the idea that I would play rookie
five and it looks like this is a blunder
because Bishop takes F3 defending the
rook and both Bishops are um are not
capturable because this Bishop's
defended through x-ray vision but I do
have a way to win material here is to
take the Rook take and then Fork the
Bishops unfortunately we didn't go into
this I think he's he probably saw that
line and for that reason he played
Bishop to B6 uh so I can't really Force
the trades with Rook E5 anymore Rook E5
would actually now be a blunder due to
Bishop takes F3 and from here I actually
took a pretty long think I had 25
minutes left
and he has uh just below 14 minutes
and I was really trying to
figure out the rights
technique the move I wanted to play
initially is 95 and I probably should
have played this move the idea being
that the bishop doesn't have too many
squares but I I was trying to calculate
Bishop D5 C4 takes takes and I'm almost
trapping the bishop in the center of the
board but he has a move Bishop g8s and I
just didn't want to trade too many pawns
off the board and okay H3 is still
attacked like Bishop D4 is coming and
this line looked a little bit murky
so instead of going for 95 I went for a
move here which I thought gave me the
best chances to win is Rook takes C6 uh
just sacrificing back the exchange we
can see I thought for about eight
minutes before uh taking the bishop now
I am aware that the engine really didn't
like this move but I I think from a
practical standpoint it just made life a
bit easier because now my plan is to
just gradually walk up with my each Pawn
so here he takes I play King G2 he goes
back and now the pawn pushing begins and
at this point I I was feeling good I
thought it was going to be a simple win
but it's a common theme in this game and
I think it's going to be simple turns
out not to be so simple because very
quickly after Bishop d8
Rook E5 Rook 2 D7 black is already
trying to get some counter play and now
I have to juggle the plan of Wishing
Upon on the king side while also making
sure my queen side doesn't crumble so I
play game F3 here with the idea that
after Rook D2 I play Rook E2 so I'm
covering the the C Pawn but then he
plays Rook D1 and now black has a plan
of Rook to A1
and it's still a little bit awkward like
pushing the pawn is a bit slow because
uh the pawn is currently tied down to
defending the Knight and the bishop is
actually really annoying on d8
so I end up playing Rook to G2 defending
the knights trying to make way for the
pawn also making sure that my king can
safely go to G4 and not have to worry
about checks
but then he plays Rook A1
and um I think I took another long think
here before playing Pawn C4 yeah it took
about four minutes uh the move I really
wanted to play was Pawn H5 but I wasn't
sure about this line because after Rook
takes A2 H6 Bishop F6 and the bishop
will always be controlling the promotion
square and black is very quick to play
Pawn A4 and make a past Pawn of his own
and in these situations where there's
past pawns on opposite flanks uh the
bishop really shows its superiority over
the Knight and I was aware of this so I
didn't want to get a situation where
it's Pawn race and he has a bishop first
Knight so instead of carelessly pushing
the pawn I play Pawns of C4 uh defending
A2 and ensuring he's not getting a pass
Pawn the drawback of this move is it
simplifies a little bit on the queen
side after takes takes and then he plays
Pawn to A4
and it's still
still kind of up in the air now I'm
thinking he maybe should have played
Rook C1 here gone after the pawn but I'm
again I haven't had a chance to check
with the engine A4 had some logic to it
there's ideas of A3 and then eventually
Rook B1 to B2 but this did give me time
to start making more progress on the
king side King G4 was played Rook C1 and
then Pawn H5 so at this point I'm
completely okay with giving away the C4
Pawn because it's all about trying to
Queen H Pawn uh he takes I play King to
F5 Rook H4 and King G6 at this point I
was feeling a little bit more
comfortable that my king is optimized
upon is very close to queening and not
only that but I'm controlling F6 squares
so Bishop F6 is uh is generally just not
possible and it's going to take the
bishop some time to get to this long
diagonal so he tried Pawn C4 here but I
played Pawn H7 and after Bishop B6 Rook
C2 uh the pawns defended and I realize I
can just go after the C Pawn because
this Rook is overworked I just want to
take on C4 next move so he plays C3 I
don't think there is much better because
of Bishop D4 I would take and then pin
so yeah C3 I take and then he plays King
to A6
and at this point I kind of just stopped
thinking and
I thought like everything is winning so
I I played the first move that came to
mind Rook H3 but I actually didn't
realize
how much fight black has left in this
position I thought okay I'd just trade
Rooks and then Queen lapaw and it should
be easy but after it takes takes he's in
time to play Bishop D4
and it takes some time to actually Queen
the pawn because in order to Queen my
Knight has to come to G7 and in that
time he's gonna try and get counter play
on The Queen side thankfully I'm winning
the race essentially after Knight F4
team B5 96 I hit the bishop gain a nice
Tempo and I play King into F7 chasing
the bishop away from the corner and then
Knight to G7 but he still didn't give up
he King A3 uh I queen and then King digs
A2 and now A3 is guaranteed for black
and I still have to figure out how to
not allow the pawn to Queen but
thankfully at this point it was
relatively simple played Queen H2 A3 and
queen to C2 and now black is a bit stuck
in the corner he plays King A1 and now
my knight comes back and there's really
not much to do here
uh he'd move back to A2 light comes back
even more and finally
yeah actually in this position I still
had to be careful if I touched my King
the game would end in a draw every king
move his stalemate uh this would be a
really
sad still made for whites but really
funny still made for black uh but I
didn't move my king I played Knight D2
and then delivered mates on B1
so it was a long fight uh big kudos to
my opponent for not giving up after an
opening gone wrong and
um yeah pretty nice finish uh 68 moves
in total I think this is my my only game
this tournament that has ended with
Checkmate on the board so it's nice to
get at least one Checkmate in uh in
these games
so thanks so much for watching again I
really appreciate all the nice comments
and feedback so far uh throughout the
videos and yeah if you have questions
leave them below if you like these
Recaps don't forget to like And
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next video